[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh grant hill's got a new book out it's
a memoir wow you know it's important if
it's a memoir
call game on sale tomorrow wherever
books are sold the uh hall of famer was
in san francisco for the celtics
warriors joins us this morning from new
york city did you know you were almost
traded for kobe bryant
no and i i don't know
you know there's so much stuff that's
out there nowadays dad
i don't know if that's entirely true or
not um and the reason i say that
i was a i was a pending free agent and
you would think if if they were really
seriously going to trade for me they
would want to know
if i would resign with them and this
being the la lakers and so
i never heard that i don't remember that
um it could have been the case but
i i i i it sounds a little
it sounds that maybe phil jackson might
have been interested in the idea but
nothing ever
you know nothing ever came of it further
than him you know sort of maybe pushing
for it you're on the lakers side kobe
was only 22 at the time you were 26
but
phil
um
i guess he had to he had to have second
thoughts on this but he wasn't sure if
he wanted to keep kobe
and uh he benched him and uh
that i guess that he uh
he thought about trading for you that
that's what i right that's the
information
yeah no and i've heard that i've heard
that i don't remember i don't remember
that being something um
back in the day and you know my detroit
years ever hearing that news do you
remember the first time you played
against kobe
um yes i do i had a great game too
um he was um
he was coming off the bench it was his
rookie year dale harris was coaching
they were playing in the forum
and uh we played them and i had like
like 34 15 and 14 we went to overtime
you know he
he was you could see the talent uh and
you could see the the the upside but
you know he was still coming off the
bench he wasn't the player that he
ultimately became the big jump the big
leap for kobe was from his first year to
his second year
his second year
think about he was coming off the bench
and was voted as an all-star starter in
that game in new york where he was
matched up with jordan
i met him for the first time though when
he was in high school
and we played the sixers in the old
spectrum
and he came by our shoot around with his
father during his senior year
and doug collins was our coach and doug
played with his dad in philly back in
the early 80s
and so i met him then and i knew about
him because duke was recruiting him so
i'm here i am trying to push in you know
you know push duke on them and like hey
you should think about duke and this and
the other he's thinking about the nba
um but now he was a great great talent
and sorely missed um i've been
kind of struggling with this last night
with draymond green
that steve jaby during the broadcast
said
officials are aware if somebody has one
technical and you want to give them a
little bit more leeway that you adjust
and this is before they decided they
weren't going to team up for the play
against jalen brown
help me understand this
that
like do players want this that that you
don't want hey we don't want to change
the outcome of this game but you're
changing it because you're allowing
draymond to stay in
and maybe you officiate him differently
than you do somebody else
i think players only want it when it
positively impacts their team
so
uh i think for last night golden state
yeah look when all that was happening
and i was in the back with steve smith
and shaq and dennis scott for nba tv
we knew that he wasn't going to get that
tech we knew he was going to stay in the
game
and um you know it's it's would you have
given him a technical grant
if if that was his first technical not
his second would you have given him
technical
i think being objective dan and and
looking at the situation uh and
understanding the rules and going by
that the rule book i think he deserved a
warranted attack but you know i think we
all understand the name the game and how
it's played and
um you know it it you know so and i
think he kind of knows that like he
played you know he he knows that
you know i got to go above and beyond to
get thrown out here in this game and uh
and he i think he kind of used it to his
advantage there in that game because he
was he was the agitator all night for
golden state which they needed and it
helped and his presence i think really
set the tone particularly on defense
but how many times did you guard jordan
and get whistled for a foul even though
you didn't foul him
i didn't guard jordan a lot i'll tell
you the other way around where he would
guard me and foul you
i'm thinking of myself y'all didn't see
that
i'm telling the officials like y'all
can't be fans he's got enough fans in
the building you got to be official
man jordan i mean joy look we all look
jordan's my goat he's my greatest of all
time
and uh and he competed on both ends of
the floor but he got away with a lot
yeah i know and i will tell you that i
got away with a lot and so when i was in
detroit i had a certain reputation and
respect and i could get calls but then i
went through the injuries and all and
then later on i'm i'm a role player in
phoenix i'm not getting those calls i'm
thinking of myself hold up y'all used to
give me that call yeah and so they they
know who's new they they know who's who
and uh and they will adapt i think
accordingly
grant hill's new memoir game is on sale
tomorrow wherever books are sold
toughest topic that you had to talk
about was what
i think two things one i think being
vulnerable about you know my
insecurities my lack of confidence
you know just sort of laying out their
warts and all you know particularly high
school college
um i think that was tough and that and i
think giving a detailed account of my
injuries
um you know one of the things and i talk
about it in the book
you know coach k used to always tell us
um
next play that was one of his mantras
next play so regardless of what happens
on the court good or bad move on to the
next play keeps you in the moment keeps
you present uh keeps you focused well i
kind of lived that way and so
going through those injuries
i didn't like dwell i didn't like have a
pity party i kept thinking okay what do
i have to do to be better what do i have
to do to get back okay i got a i got a
crutch walk i got to use crutches for
three months
i'm gonna get stronger like you know
everything was just sort of to get
through it and to ultimately try to come
back
and i think the process of going back
and living in that moment
and and really trying to like okay what
what was i feeling what was happening
and unpacking all of that like
that was actually hard and and at
moments
and at times made me upset
because i felt like you know i felt like
the medical community let me down and i
felt like i was on this incredible
trajectory
and as good as things were they could
have been better and i never really got
a chance to see that through so
sort of living look i almost had my leg
amputate like you know that people don't
know the story at all in terms of what
happened
um and
and so to be able to kind of go through
that on one hand it was i think
ultimately
liberating and therapeutic but it was
hard to do in terms of executing
who's going to be most upset
by what's written in this book
um
i don't know that's a good question um
i'll tell you one thing i i and i felt
like this
i had to be authentic and honest and
transparent
but like i had a you know my junior year
at duke
was not smooth sailing and i i talk
about
some of my issues and angst and and you
know and and
a frustration with coach k
and um i get into that and you know a
lot of it had to do with me being hurt
and not being able to play
um
but you know i'm a little worried like
you know coach is gonna
you know he may not know all of this and
he may not know you know that i was
thinking all of this it was going
through my mind and and uh and so i was
very very nervous about that and this is
how people but i felt like it's
important to put that all out there and
as great as those years were at duke and
magical years and we had great success
you know as my wife says it's not all
rainbows and lollipops and there were
moments of tension and so to share that
um
with something i was nervous about and
nervous more more you know
more nervous about how coach k would
receive that and now i did give him the
book and he wrote a blurb but i'm not
sure
[Laughter]
the book is called game it's uh from
grant hill on sale tomorrow wherever
books are sold great to catch up with
you again and uh thanks as always grant
all right appreciate you dan thank you
all right we'll take a break last call
for phone calls right after this